DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
WHEN THEY SENT PEOPLE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SENDS TROOPS.
>> SPEAKING WITH GENERAL MATTIS,
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING THINGS
MILITARILY UNTIL WE CAN HAVE A
WALL AND PROPER SECURITY.
WE ARE GOING TO BE GUARDING OUR
BORDER WITH THE MILITARY.
IT'S A BIG STEP.
WE REALLY HAVEN'T DONE THAT
BEFORE.
>> Greg: ANY RESPONSE ORDER
WAVING THE CARAVAN THROUGH HIS
DRASTIC.
IF YOU WANT TO PROVE A NEED FOR
THE WALL, SAID 1,000 PEOPLE TO
OUR BORDER AS A POLITICAL STUNT.
I MEAN, ARE WE SURE TRUMP DIDN'T
PLAN THIS?
HE WILL NEVER GET A BETTER
VISUAL AID FOR HIS ARGUMENT.
ALL SOCIETIES FROWN ON LINE
CUTTING.
THE EXCEPTION, DIRE NEED.
THAT'S WHY THE CARAVAN
BACKFIRED.
IT WAS POLITICAL, CALCULATED,
DESIGNED TO CHALLENGE THE IDEA
OF A BORDER.
IT HURTS EVERYONE WHO REALLY
WANTS TO COME HERE.
JUST ASK ANYONE WHO DID IT
LEGALLY.
YOU WONDER WHY TRUMP'S APPROVAL
CLIMBS.
THIS STORY IS THE LONG-TERM
TREND, NOT THE ABSOLUTE LEVEL.
WHY THE RISE, EVEN IF THE MEDIA
PUSHES COLLUSION, STORMY, AND
CHAOS.
COULD IT BE AMERICA LOVES THE
UNDERDOG?
THE MEDIA HAS MADE TRUMP INTO
THAT VERY THING BY RELENTLESSLY
DEMONIZING HIM.
DESPITE A PANICKY PRESS, ISSUES
SEEM TO MATTER MORE TO YOU
WITHIN THE MEDIA'S MUD.
PERHAPS THOSE OBSESSING OVER THE
LATEST RUMOR MAY ACTUALLY BE
HELPING TRUMP OUT.
HOW HILARIOUS.
THE SAME NETWORK THAT ELECTED
TRUMP, CNN, MAY END UP
REELECTING HIM.
JESSE COME EVERY TIME SOMETHING
HAPPENS IMMIGRATION WISE, IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE WALL.
IT'S ABOUT TRUMP.
THEY CANCELED THE CARAVAN.
THE CARAVAN WAS COMING HERE.
THEY CANCELED IT.
BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S REACTION.
ERGO TRUMP IS THE --
>> Jesse: CAN YOU USE THE LINE
YOU USED?
>> Greg: CARAVAN BECAME
CARA-VANT.
>> Jesse: WHEN OBAMA SAYS
NATIONAL GUARDS, HE'S CONSIDERED
TOUGH.
TRUMP DOESN'T, HE'S CONSIDERED
RACIST.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUING -- I
THINK THE REASON HIS POPULARITY
IS GOING UP IS HE IS DEFENDING
THE COUNTRY.
ALL HE'S DOING IS DEFENDING THE
COUNTRY.
DEFENDING WORKERS WAGES,
DEFENDING THAT TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY.
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
THEMSELVES WANT THE WALL.
LET'S GIVE THE WORKERS WHAT THEY
WANT.
I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS
WANTED, JUAN.
IF YOU ARE ANTI-WALL AND
ANTI-TROOPS ON THE BORDER, YOU
MUST BE PRO-CARTEL.
ALL OF THE HEROIN COMING ACROSS
FROM MEXICO, THE CARTELS ARE
SENDING IT.
EVERY TIME A MIGRANT PAYS A
COYOTE, THE COYOTE PAYS THE
CARTEL.
THE ONLY THING THAT'S GOING TO
STOP THE CARTELS ARE A WALL AND
TROOPS.
HOW ELSE ARE YOU GOING TO FIGHT
THE CARTELS?
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION COSTS THIS
COUNTRY HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR.
THE WALL COSTS 200 BILLION.
THE WALL COST 20 BILLION.
I'M NOT VERY GOOD AT MATH.
TO SPEND 20 TO SAY 100, THAT
MAKES SENSE TO ME.
>> Greg: JUAN, I THINK HE
DIRECTED AT YOU.
YOU ARE FROM THE CARTEL.
>> Juan: I KNOW.
I KNOW.
THE THING ABOUT LISTENING TO
JESSE IS YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
START.
YOU LISTEN.
FOR EXAMPLE, DO YOU KNOW THAT
MOST ILLEGAL DRUGS DO NOT COME
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Jesse: HEROIN IS COMING
>> Juan: MIGHT RETYPE
SOMETHING.
MORE PEOPLE ARE KILLED BY
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS USED
ILLEGALLY.
IT'S SOMETHING LIKE TWO TIMES AS
MANY AS PEOPLE KILLED BY HEROIN.
IN TERMS OF --
>> Jesse: WE ARE FIGHTING THAT
CRISIS AS WELL.
>> Juan: SLOWED DOWN.
IF YOU CAN'T WON -- WHEN I TALK,
I UNDERSTAND.
OTHERWISE LET ME TALK.
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE IF
YOU SAY THIS IS BECAUSE WE WANT
TO STOP DRUGS, IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE BECAUSE GUESS WHAT?
SO MANY OF THE DRUGS ARE NOT
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY ARE COMING FROM LEGAL PORTS
OF ENTRY WHERE THEY ARE IN
AIRPLANES OR SHIPS AND SECRETLY
STATIONED THERE.
THAT'S HOW THEY      THEY ARE GE
THAT'S HOW THEY      THEY ARE GT
THAT'S HOW THEY      THEY ARE GN
THAT'S HOW THEY      THEY ARE GG
THAT'S HOW THEY      THEY ARE GI
THAT'S HOW THEY      THEY ARE G,
NOT ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> Jesse: WRONG.
>> Juan: ASKED THE PEOPLE AT
THE DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY.
>> Greg: WHY ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK ON THE GRATEFUL SO --
WORK ON THE BORDER SO GRATEFUL
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> Juan: IF THIS WAS FOR
PEOPLE, YOU WOULD BE SAYING
THOSE POOR PEOPLE, HE DOES WANT
THE GOVERNMENT TO COME IN.
WHY ARE WE SPENDING MONEY FOR
NOTHING?
>> Jesse: THE BORDER PATROL
WORKERS ARE THE ONLY GOVERNMENT
WORKERS YOU DON'T SUPPORT.
>> Juan: I SUPPORT EVERYONE,
ESPECIALLY THE FBI AND CIA,
ALWAYS BELEAGUERED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Kimberly: CHANGING
SUBJECTS.
>> Juan: IT SO IMPORTANT TO
SAY WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A
PRESIDENT WHO'S DESPERATE.
I THINK HE IS SO UPSET BY ANN
COULTER ATTACKING HIM FOR HIS
FAILURE TO BUILD A WALL OR GAIN
FUNDING FOR THE WALL THAT NOW HE
SAYS I'M GOING TO SEND TROOPS.
JESSE, HERE IS ANOTHER THING YOU
ARE WRONG ON.
OBAMA AND BOORSE AND TROOPS.
GUESS WHAT.
THEY SENT THEM ONE COMMAND A
SITUATION WHERE THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE, THE CHILDREN WERE COMING
IN BIG NUMBERS.
AND TO ADD ADMINISTRATIVE AID.
>> Jesse: THOSE GUYS WERE
MAKING SANDWICHES.
>> Juan: HE SAID HE WANTS TO
SEND THEM -- THIS IS SUCH
BALONEY.
>> Kimberly: I'M GOING TO SHUT
YOU BOTH DOWN.
I'M GOING TO BUILD A WALL RIGHT
HERE.
HERE IS ONE OF THE MOST
RIDICULOUS THING JUAN JUST SAID,
WHICH IS THAT ANN COULTER IS
LIKE HELEN OF TROY AND THE
PRESIDENT GOT SO UPSET WITH ANN
COULTER BEING UPSET THAT HE'S
NOW SENDING ALL OF THE TROOPS.
SHE'S WORRIED ABOUT IT.
>> Juan: HE IS WORRIED THAT
ANN COULTER REPRESENTS HOW MANY
OF THE TRUMP PEOPLE.
HE IS GOING TO BUILD A WALL.
THERE IS NO WALL.
>> Kimberly: HE IS GOING TO
BUILD IT.
WE HAVE TO MIMIC JUAN BECAUSE
THEN HE UNDERSTANDS.
HE IS GOING TO BUILD A WALL AND
HE'S GOING TO ENFORCE THE LAWS
ON THE BOOKS.
UPHOLD IMMIGRATION AND MAKE SURE
WE PREVENT ILLEGAL ENTRY.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT?
THIS IS ABOUT BEING FOR JUSTICE
AND HONORING THE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS.
>> Juan: MY RESPONSES MOST
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OVERSTAY
THEIR VISAS.
THEY DON'T COME ACROSS ANY
BORDER, INCLUDING OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
WE ENFORCE THE LAWS.
>> Kimberly: THEY SHOULDN'T BE
DOING THAT EITHER.
>> Greg: DANA, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Greg: WHEN I LOOK AT
DONALD TRUMP, I ASSUME HE HAS NO
IDEOLOGY BECAUSE EVERYTHING
SEEMS TO CHANGE.
I THINK HIS IDEOLOGY IS BASED ON
ORDERING THE IDEA THAT CUTTING
IN LINE IN ANY SHAPE OR FORM IS
SEEN AS SOMEHOW WRONG.
>> Dana: THERE IS A
FUNDAMENTAL VALUE OF FAIRNESS
THAT RUNS THROUGH EVERYBODY.
IN ANY CULTURE, CHILDREN,
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS FAIRNESS.
AS YOU GET OLDER, YOU ADD THINGS
ONTO BACK.
THE POLL NUMBERS THEY WANTED TO
BRING UP, GALLUP HAD ONE THAT,
IT WASN'T SPECIFIC TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT IT'S ABOUT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME.
IT IS THE FIRST TIME IN MANY
YEARS YOUNG PEOPLE, NOW
MAJORITY, 61% BELIEVE THEY WILL
BE BETTER OFF THAN THEIR
PARENTS.
FROM 2009 TO MAYBE LAST YEAR,
THAT NUMBER WAS ALMOST BELOW 50%
OF PEOPLE STARTED WORRYING ABOUT
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
EVERY GENERATION HAD DONE BETTER
EVERY GENERATION HAD DONE BETTE
BETTER.
THE ECONOMY AS PART OF THAT.
PERHAPS LAW & ORDER AS WELL AS
BUT THE FAIRNESS ISSUE IS ONE
THAT EVERYBODY CAN UNDERSTAND.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S WHY
THE CARAVAN PRESENTED SUCH A
VISUAL.
PEOPLE LAUGH ABOUT THE WALL.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE THIS CARAVAN
AND YOU GO, THE ONLY THING THAT
CAN STOP A CARAVAN IS A WALL.
>> Dana: THE GOVERNMENT OF
HONDURAS IS NOT HAPPY WITH THE
CARAVAN.
THE HONDURANS HAVE TRIED TO BE
HELPFUL TO THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE COOPERATIVE ON THE DEA
ISSUE.
THEY'RE ASKING FOR SUPPORT AND
HELP.
NIKKI HALEY PROMISED THEY WOULD
HAVE MORE OF IT.
AND REMEMBER THEY WERE ONE OF
THE ONLY TWO COUNTRIES, HONDURAS
AND GUATEMALA, THAT BACKED UP
THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE WANTED TO
MOVE THE EMBASSY FROM TEL AVIV
TO JERUSALEM.
>> Jesse: I WOULD LIKE TO POSE
THIS QUESTION TO JUAN.
WE HAVE A NICE CAFE UNDERNEATH
THE BUILDING.
PEOPLE LINED UP AND GET SALADS.
LET'S PRETEND YOU ARE LINED UP
FOR A SALAD AND YOU SEE SOMEONE
EGREGIOUSLY CUT IN FRONT OF YOU
AND START ORDERING A SALAD IN
FRONT OF YOU.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S FAIR, JUAN?
WHY IS IT FAIR WHEN ILLEGAL
ALIENS ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND CUT IN LINE FOR
EVERYONE ELSE WAS WAITING TO
BECOME U.S. CITIZENS?
>> Juan: WHO SAID IT WAS FAIR?
>> Jesse: YOU!
YOU DON'T MIND IF THEY ARE
COMING IN.
>> Juan: I NEVER SAID ANY SUCH
THING.
THAT'S YOUR CHARACTER BECAUSE HE
CAN'T DEAL WITH THE REAL
ARGUMENT.
THE REAL ARGUMENT IS SO THAT
HAVE -- 9071 AT THIS LOW A
LEVEL.
YOU HAVE YOUR GUY, THE GUY THAT
YOU AND GREG ARE TRUMPETING.
>> Greg: I DON'T TRUMPET.
YOU ARE BETTER THAN THAT, JUAN.
>> Juan: WHILE YOU ARE SAYING
HOSANNA TO TRUMP, THERE IS NO
REALITY EXCEPT THAT HE IS LIKE
THE GUY ON THE CORNER.
I WOULD SEND TROOPS TO THE
BORDER.
I'M A TOUGH GUY.
>> Jesse: 300,000 ILLEGAL
ALIENS CAUGHT CROSSING THE
BORDER LAST YEAR.
THINK ABOUT THE ONES WE DIDN'T
CATCH.
SEEMS LIKE A LOG.
>> Juan: SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE
BIGGER PROBLEMS.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, WRAP IT UP.
>> Kimberly: I THINK THE THING
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO HONOR HIS
PROMISES.
IT IS SOMETHING HE'S QUITE
SERIOUS AND CONSISTENT ABOUT
ABOUT ENFORCING THE BORDERS AND
THE LAWS MAY BE NEEDS TO SEND
TROOPS COME HE'S GOING TO DO IT.
IT'S WITHIN HIS RIGHT AND HIS
AUTHORITY TO DO SO.
>> Greg: THIS IS THE GUY WHO